بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
كتين الرياض ض الصالحين
الحافظ النووي رحمه الله تعالى
يقول وعن ابي سعيد وابي هريره
ابي سعيد وابي هريره رضي الله عنهما
عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
ما يصيب المسلم
من نصب ولا وصب
ولا هم ولا حزن ولا اذن ولا غم حتى الشوكه
يشاكها
الا كفر الله بها من خطاياه
متفق عليه
والوصب
المرض
بخاري
ابي هريره
ابي سعيد الخدري رضي الله عنهما
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ملم
‏any
sadness
any har
any decks
the musl
every
not let any of those go
اللهم
خطاياه
الا كفر الله بها من خطاياه
كفر
اي حط عنه وستر
لان كفر كاف والفاء والراء في لغه العرب
هذه الماده تدل على الستر
والاخفاء ولذلك يقال
للفلاح
كافرا
لانه يضع الحبه ويسترها بالتراب
ويقال لمن جحد الاسلام
ورد دعوه الانبياء كافرا لانه
يصدر الحق بالباطل
وكما قال الله تعالى وجحدوا بها
واستيقنتها
انفسهم
وقوله الا كفر الله بها من خطاياه
اي حط عنه من خطاياه
وستر هذه الخطايا عن الخلق يوم القيامه
الله سبحانه وتعالى use this as a كفاره
الله
take
life
imposition and use it to
not
‏trud
الله سبحانه وى الله
‏will
concealed from him and
this is
here all things
المسلم من نصب النصب في اللغه
التعب
ولا وصب والوصب المرض
ولا هم هم بالشيء
بمعنى انه فكر فيه وثقل في ذهنه ولا حزن
الحزن
والحزن
بينهما فروق
وبينهما عموم وخصوص
لكن يجوز ان يقال حزن وحزن
واذهب عنا الحزن واذهب عنا الحزن في
قراءتين
ولا اذن من الاذيه ولا غم
الغم هو
زياده في الهم حتى يغتم الانسان حزنا
وشده حتى الشوكه يشاكها
الا كفر الله بها من خطاياه
[Silence]
الله
وعن ابن مسعود رضي الله عنه قال دخلت على
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وهو يوعك يوعك
يعني عنده حمى الوعك الحمى
من المرض ابن مسعود
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم فكان هذا هذه الحادثه
عند مرض موته صلى الله عليه وسلم
فقلت يا رسول الله انك توعك وعكا شديدا
صلى الله عليه وسلم
اجل اني اوعك كما يوعك الرجلان منكم
قلت
ذلك ان لك اجرين
ويسال يستفهم ذلك انت توعك كما يوعك كما
يوعك الرجلان منا ذلك ان لك اجرين
قال اجل
كذلك
said yesed my is equent of two among you
and so i asked him i said is that
because you have the reward of
and said that is
ما من مسلم يصيبه اذنك
فما فوقها
الا كفر الله بها سيئاته
وحطت عنه ذنوبه
كما تحط الشجره ورقها
noy
him
and anything above
الله
expation
sin and
sin anddeeds will be
taken off of him and he will shed his
sins every time he encounters a
difficulty just a tree loses its
leaves
[Silence]
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يحط عنا سيئاتنا وان يكفر عنا ذنوبنا
نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يعفو عنا وان يغفر
لنا وان يرحمنا وان يتوب علينا وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين وجزاكم
الله خيرا
за